and i'll be moving the mic closer to my
mouth at this time
you're gonna have to wash my mic because
it's been inside my mouth
i haven't really like been this close to
anything
in a long time
on the brook and connor show i think
it'd be good for people to know um
that they're probably you guys are
probably gonna argue a lot sure yeah
sure yeah and um what what types of
things will you argue about
stuff
for sure
we gotten a bit of a
tiff about taylor swift recently yeah
that was a big
fight that we've had mm-hmm
yeah i think i think a lot of things um
nfts will argue about yeah like which
ones are cooler like which what is this
what is it
really
what what is nft
what
and really just
it's everything of the sort everything
you can imagine every i don't think we
really if
wordle is
an integral part of right
um if it's a society thing competitive
sport you name it honestly we have she's
she got carpal tunnel from wordle and i
was saying well that's
are you are you doing in like are you
like a three person are you doing them a
three a three like are you doing them in
three the wordles
if she was at three
out of ten i think that yeah and cody i
think you better work your shirt around
to myself i'm saying do you do them in
the three in the third row is that when
you complete them like i've seen i see a
lot of people and i did it one time and
i was like all over my story forgive me
for being confused um well i'm saying if
you were like a real world person yeah
no cody you're good because it's like i
told you it's competitive amongst the
world community i would well yeah you're
fine um i would say
i'm averaging at about a a four and a
half
okay at this rate do you okay don't let
cody bully you into saying you're a four
and a half okay that's that's not what
this is just i didn't mean that this is
pretty big i was gonna say where's your
shirt by the way you're gonna flip it
around cody to my side
because that is definitely not
yeah you're not a woman leaving me i
know i didn't mean that i stand like i
was trying to talk
i stand with brooke
but i'm like a four and a half a solid
four and a half with wordle brand and
life in general it's fun right yeah do
you see that it got it got bought by who
new york times actually i don't know if
he sold it but the new york times has
purchased wordle yes i'm not playing it
anymore a popular world word game that
became a viral sensation in a matter of
months but it's funny because my friend
marcus yeah he's i guess he's he's big
into word games oh okay i didn't know
but he was like dude if you think
world's fun you should check out the new
york times crossword mini of the day oh
so i've been playing that oh nice which
is now going to be wordle probably well
i think they're going to add it to that
app because there's another spelling
game in there that's a lot of fun too so
i've been like
just i know a ton of words now nice do
you play little yeah ludo is hard i feel
like you would like ludo what
no what
you're switching your shirt
uh
[Laughter]
so much harder they got it for they
didn't disclose a number but and they
reported on themselves the new york
times has purchased they're like why are
you that's in third person
you
it was just a seven figure number that
they didn't disclose which like
everybody in the world is playing at
seven figures so how many figures is
seven is that millions like a million or
nine so it could be one million dollars
that they bought it for i feel like it's
worth
more but i don't know i don't play it
throw a number out there man don't be
afraid i mean like
if some people can get spotify deals for
60 million dollars for three years i
feel like wordle's at least worth a
hundred million a hundred million yeah
so are you saying the 60 million deal
that
that that person got you say are you
saying that that maybe was too much i'm
just confused about numbers in general
like i don't know what anything is worth
like now we've got again back to nfts
i'm like
i'm like
really like i have no
so you're saying the the caller daddy
podcast is overvalued
no i didn't
interesting connor you're saying a
woman's podcast yeah
[Laughter]
drenched in sweat over here oh my god i
just [ __ ]
again
all the comments gonna be like cool
episode but really [ __ ] up when connor
inappropriately touched brooke oh god
i'm getting a cease and desist it's just
that brook makes a podcast
it's okay anyone like common side you
can curse them yeah yeah
i don't know
no dude i i want to talk about little
because i think it's way harder than
working so harder because there's like
six total words you can choose from wait
like i'll try boobs
let's try it let's do this one i know
people are gonna get [ __ ] pissed that
if we solve this and they're like oh i
didn't do it yet today like i don't
think anyone really does little right
not many people not so many people all
right titties
no no no no no no that's where the y t i
t one that's one of the examples
they're like look
it's never been
it's never boobs
that was actually my nickname in college
that's titty queef
penis
is a good one yeah it's a good starting
point
not in the right place okay
um
um
if you're listening on audio
this is what a retirement home sounds
like
bingo herpe
good one cody herpes try it
it may not take herp herpe yeah is it is
there a scene one singular just one cold
sore
yo doc you got a herp all right you know
what i don't really know i thought it'd
be way easier to think of dirty words
but it's
it's hard
nipples
the p is silent in kegel
oh i just thought of a horrible one
grope that was yesterday's oh what i
don't know that was gape that was
that was gaper or something
oh my god hearing you say that
seriously no gate was yesterday
[Music]
another try
but there's that's four no paper
hey that's a gaper yeah yeah
this might be yesterday's
my boy's a big gaper oh there's no r
whatever try it let's see yeah [ __ ] it
just do it oh no that's not a real word
it's gaped
yeah yeah yeah oh do it gaped
but if you're the person doing the
gaping would you be able to use gaped in
a sense oh my god my god
well i did this yesterday oh thank you
but could you guys do me a favor and say
and use gaped in a sentence yeah
i mean
if you want me and my boy were chilling
last night and then i got totally gay
that could mean anything right yeah
no we couldn't that means one thing
that means one thing no but we in the
english language we interchange stuff
all the time
i don't
personally
really nothing i could figure it out you
know i'm a little bit lost are you
saying you you don't know what gapes is
i mean i know it in a non-sexual way
like well like that was a gaping what is
it what is it called gaping hole and i i
think i mean that completely non-sexual
but so then what do you think it would
be sexually so sorry about the situation
yeah exactly is that it like we're using
deep as a verb that means that gape is a
verb in this situation to gape or not
that is the question of the day all
right that's what shakespeare always
says
like let's imagine like this is like
a non-sexual gaping horse right
this is also a sexual one i just feel
like gaper would make more sense
gaper
like meaning what like that's a gaper
like a slang
she's got a gaper yeah no it's usually
gape gaped
after
yeah so that's why i escaped
and thank you for teaching me something
new today
yeah because as a woman i need to learn
that kind of stuff yeah guys are gross
you know yeah that we know well no if i
think it's just about being transparent
if this is a learning moment for anyone
it's it's all of us we're here we're
learning with everybody yeah like what
does gaped mean yeah
you two are clearly not perverse family
consumers
you